before we get back to all that news and
there is a lot of news today we have
some headlines of our own this morning
here at CBS we are announcing some major
changes today moving forward working to
get even better at what we do so you
might have been reading about all the
speculation we thought today would be a
good day to hear it from the horse's
mouth hello horses because this is big
day for Nora dollars she's been named
have you heard anchor and managing
editor of the CBS Evening News in our
world of television journalism there is
no job that carries a prouder tradition
or a more crucial and current
responsibility Jeff Glor as we all know
is a fantastic journalist and trusted
colleague here his award-winning
reporting has shed light on important
issues and highlighted the humanity in
our world his conversations you should
know with CBS News continue and we all
hope very much that he will continue
working here it will be his decision
Nora will take the helm at the CBS
Evening News this summer and starting in
the fall she will anchor from Washington
DC that's big as we focus even more on
stories from the center of power that
impact the lives of Americans across the
country
Nora by the way will also serve as a
network's lead anchor for political
coverage reporting on primaries and
election nights across the country and
yeah you got a lot of jobs and she
continued her role as contributing
correspondent on 60 minutes
Bravo Norah O'Donnell thank you I think
about the legacy I think about the
history of CBS News and it's incredibly
humbling to accept this position I was
looking through some things that Walter
Cronkite said you know and he he said I
can't imagine a person becoming a
success in life without giving
everything they've got
and so I'm gonna give this everything
I've got I believe that and it's CBS
news you know I don't stand on the
shoulders of my colleagues they carry me
on their backs and so this is a great
moment I think for all of us at CBS News
as Susan Zorinsky has taken the helm
it's the moment we've all been waiting
for
I think there's been such speculation
about it but the truth is a new era
begins and it's a great era listen and
you are the third woman single woman to
host an evening broadcast and you're
doing it from Walter Cronkite's chair
that's very cool we're not done yet hold
on John Dickerson will be moving across
57th Street we're on 57th Street by the
way
to join 60 minutes as a correspondence
did you hear I said 60 minutes
he will bring along all his insight and
skills as an interviewer and writer to
the number-one news broadcast in the
history of TV John will also be a
contributing anchor for all of our
biggest political nights
hello best-selling author 60 minutes is
big I know you know as a family we used
to gather around and watch 60 minutes on
something right so that that stopwatch
ticking is in you know is in my head and
has been since of little kids so that
little kid is pinballing all over the
place but you know as a 60 minutes
correspondent I have to have some
decorum so I'm not gonna I'm not going
to just totally flip out because I also
owe a lot of gratitude to you guys and
also everybody here for what's been a
great you know year abroad and and we'll
get we'll get to that and and our
goodbyes because I'm not gonna start
blowing my time queue because you know
after a year of behaving but I'm glad
you also mentioned Jeff's yeah
accomplishments but Nora what an amazing
thing you know my mom 60 years ago
worked at this network and I don't think
she ever would have believed that there
could be a day where someone with your
skill and talent would be in the anchor
chair so congratulations I can't wait to
see what the congratulations you know we
were old road warriors out on the
campaign trail in our 20s so thank you
that means a lot and along with John's
political skills your charm and musical
talent and athletics back here at CBS
this morning I'm going to be joined by
Anthony Mason and Tony decouple starting
May 20th at the table there is Anthony
with Bruce yeah three decades covering
the world for CBS News most recently as
anchor of CBS this morning Saturday as
he says and since joining CBS News in
2016
Tony as you know has knocked it out of
the park with great reporting and news
making interviews he's also established
himself at CBS Sunday morning doing
powerful and provocative cover stories
the news should rarely be about us and
sometimes what you read isn't even true
and it can I just take a minute to just
go off script about that yeah here we
were Thursday I know I'm supposed to
stick to the script but I just gotta say
this here we first day I'm flying to
London to do the Royal we're working on
a prime-time Royal special the news
breaks 130 the Gail is elbowing No
is insisting that Nora leave CBS this
morning it's so amazing to me nor that
after seven years together that now
people would say that you and I have
some beef I have no beef with you you
have no beef of me Tina Brown summed it
up very nicely she said this never
happens to men this kind of cutthroat
business that the the reality is it's
two great jobs for two great women she
said and I and I also think I know that
that's true I look at Susan Zorinsky who
if you haven't heard outside the
building is a badass in our building
she's our new CBS president and when she
announced that she was - when it was
announced she was taking this job in
January she said there's going to be
some changes there's going to be some
changes she's gonna look at the lay of
the land and decide she could have come
in here with a weed whacker and we'd all
be on 57th Street going taxi but what
she decided to do was take a look and
see what she thought would work best
right and what job would suit our role
you know this is a business about
ratings and when the ratings don't work
they make changes and so they're making
changes that they hope will lead to
better things and I believe I'm with you
I'm going to give it a hundred and ten
percent - yeah as will you Joe yeah
great advice and Oprah gave me some
great advice not to listen to those in
the in the cheap seats it's not the
critic who counts yeah and I know you
have Oprah but I want to thank you for
being my work because thank you you have
made me better in everything I have done
well I don't know about that you know
even going to Washington
I know Kirby says mom please don't talk
too long because most people don't even
know what you're talking about they're
not following this the way you are yeah
but it has bothered me because even you
know we've had a lot of bad press coming
from inside the building which i think
is very disturbing to me because I think
most people that work here support
respect admire each other cheer each
other on even going to Washington with
Susan's rinsky's idea not yours but I
think that it makes it will make
everything better and different so I am
cheering you on and I in the words of
Grace Tracy your daughter we all want to
crush it like a popsicle that's what she
says to Norah when she comes to watch us
home we will stick to them we're all
very excited about CBS news original
reporting of great storytelling that
we're saying wrap it up Casey which is
why I want to take 0.5 minutes or so to
give my
barks okay and now thank you all
yeah sighting news ahead for all of us